- Ah, I miss the breeze.
- Yikes, y'all look rough.
WHAT? I DON’T LOOK GREAT EITHER.
- I’m just excited for another midseason trip to a
normal, not creepy American house!
- I feel like we used to have better records.
[Knocking on door]
- Bro…how’re the vibes?
- What the f--k is he talking about?
- Ya know, the goofy good-good shish, brah?
- Sorry, we can’t let you into the playoff house..
- Wait, where’d they go?
- I’m sure everything is fine.
I have total situational awareness.
- I’m having trouble getting reception, ehh?
[Phone buzzing]
- [Alvin Kamara:] Yeah, same.
[Pounding on door]
- Come in!
Oh, sorry, Canadian reflex.
- [Together:] AHHH!!!
- It’s two masked guys and Kyler Murray!
- No. It’s not me, fam.
- Nah, that’s Kyler.
- He’s very recognizable.
- Hey, I’m Joe Burrow, and it doesn’t even bother me that I’m on the Bengals.
- [Together:] Ahhh!
- ♪♪♪ I love you, but just one question ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Aren't we all doomed for regression? ♪♪♪
[Record skipping]
♪♪♪ Doomed for regression ♪♪♪
- Laser kick!
♪♪♪ Doomed— ♪♪♪
- Oww.
- [Together:] Oh yeah, Washington was in the playoffs last year.
- I won't be long, in the NFC East we just sorta treat the playoffs like a timeshare.
Enjoy the playoffs!
- Aww, thank you. We won't.
- Hot Rod, has gone cold.
- They sunk our Blankenship!
- We need to get over to the playoff lock cabin!
- Who wants s'mores?!
- I don't want s'more. I want s'most.
- OK, I think it's this key.
- Hey, what's up, fam? I'm everywhere.
- OH GOD, THEY MUST HAVE GOOD COACHES.
- OK, so the mistake most slashers make is
you gotta make sure they’re dead.
Analytics prefers an extra stab or two.
- Yeah, sure whatever. What are you wearing, bro?
- Get it? I'm Zac Sailor!
I thought we were all dressing up for the Halloween episode.
- Mmm, I love the Chase.
- But I'm Chase!
- Different Chase.
- OW, OH, SOARIE FOR SCREAMING.
- They got Claypool.
I think my window has closed,
But you could still make a run.
- But we forgot to invest in defense!
- Then win in a shootout.
- Don’t f--king touch me. I said I’m out.
- Coming for that playoff spot.
- [Patrick Mahomes:] EAT PIGSKIN, PLAYOFF STRANGERS! AHHH!!!
Hello?
- Your record is the same...
AS THE BRONCOS!
[Screaming]
- We are hearing reports that a dangerous man has
escaped from Detroit.
- [Mahomes:] What happened here?
- I know! I can’t believe this either.
- AHHH!